am demandé à sophie qu'elle signifiait
le x2 d'addex après l'intervention de
christelle et après la vienne je pense
qu'il ya plus de doute on va parler de
sexe avec christelle on a parlé du sexe
des femmes du plaisir féminin
je vais vous parler d'autre chose
quelque chose qui est un peu tabou alors
je ne sais pas parce que je sais pas si
vous vous rendez compte mais en fait
nous on vous voit plutôt dans le noir
donc je ne sais pas combien vous étiez
de femmes à vous sentir concernés par le
sujet de christelle et je ne sais pas
combien vous serez de vieux à vous
sentir concernés par le sujet que je
porte aujourd'hui vous le savez
également un télex on a pour principe de
faire un sujet court et bien ça tombe
bien également parce que je vais
peut-être vous l'apprendre mais les
études nous disent que un rapport entre
trois et sept minutes
les deux partenaires sont satisfaits et
un rapport entre 7 et 13 minutes
les partenaires sont comblés on
considérera que vous êtes mon partenaire
et que donc en 13 minutes je vais
essayer de vous combler
la sexualité des vieux c'est beaucoup de
croyances comme j'ai décidé de faire
court pour vous combler je vais en
énumérer au moins 10 aujourd'hui les
vieux serait ou aurait une sexualité
en fait il en aurait pas et quand je dis
qu'ils on n'aurait pas c'est qu'ils
auraient pas d'activités à pratiquer pas
pensé pas d'intérêt autres croyances 6
en avait j'en avais leur vie sexuelle
serait stable monogamique la tendresse
c'est à dire que la passion le désir
explicite ne serait pas pour les vieux
l'hétérosexualité également ne
concernerait que les vieux qui
s'imaginent ici des vues homosexuels à
part peut-être ceux d'entre nous qui
sont homosexuels mais des vieux
bisexuels non 50 nuance degrés dans les
ehpad
je suis pas sûr que vous y pensiez mais
au-delà de ça sur tout ce que j'espère
c'est que quelque part je vous choque
pourquoi je vous choque parce que je
vous amène à vous poser la question à
vous représenter la sexualité de vos
parents voire de vos grands parents ou
arrières grands parents
selon l'âge que vous avez ici dans la
salle moi je suis issu l'immaculée
conception
mes parents n'ont jamais fait l'amour
ma fille est dans la salle
ma chérie je n'ai jamais fait l'amour on
peut être gêné quand on parle de la
sexualité des vieux mais finalement moi
je trouve ça sain qu'on soit choqué
s'est pas automatiquement naturel de se
représenter la sexualité de l'autre
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que dans
les autres croyances on pourrait pas
être grands parents et avoir une vie
sexuelle
là c'est pour ça que j'espère que ça
vous arrange ne pas imaginer vos parents
en train garder vos petits enfants à vos
enfants et que pendant la sieste peut
être eux ils s'en font une de sieste qui
est la leur
les vieux
ne sont vus comme des personnes malades
fragiles démentent tout un cortège
d'image négative de représentation
sociale
j'ai entendu que la sexualité la
pratique sexuelle étaient déconseillés
ça pourrait leur faire mal leur causer
des douleurs
ils pourraient en mourir
si jamais j'avais des orgasmes trop pour
leur petit coeur
la sexualité des vieux lorsqu'elle
s'exprime
ça serait uniquement sous l'angle de la
perversité un vieux pervers plus pervers
convoque tous gotlib une vieille
lubrique
et si jamais si jamais il avait en
intérêts ça serait uniquement pour des
personnes jeunes bah ouais bah oui parce
que quand je vous parle de tout ça de
quoi je vous parle je vous parle d'une
société où la jeunesse règne société
hagist jeuniste où on n'a pas le droit
d'être vieux en fait vous avez remarqué
j'ai même pas donner des définitions de
vieux puisque personne s'entend sur
cette définition fut un temps on pouvait
encore dire qu'on était vieux quand les
différentes réformes des assurances
sociales nous mettait la retraite à 60
ans alors là maintenant peu plus du tout
savoir vraiment quand on est vieux
ma fille me rappelle d'ailleurs
régulièrement je vais avoir 40 ans cette
année que je suis vieille quand même je
suis vieille quand est-ce qu'on est
vieux on est toujours vieux dans le
regard de l'autre
mais on est aussi toujours jeune par
rapport à quelqu'un d'autre dans cette
société hagist où la jeunesse prime le
vieux comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure qui est vu malade comme ça avec
sa canne là des images d'epinal que vous
avez qu'on a tous comment est-ce qu'ils
pourraient pratiquer une sexualité qui
est elle-même standardisés normalisée
là je remercie également les stèles
d'être intervenu avant moi parce qu'elle
a démonté déjà aussi beaucoup d'idées
reçues sur cette sexualité on ne parle
que d'une sexualité performante
christelle nous l'a dit sportive
avec une société également ou jouir est
quasiment devenu impératif où il
faudrait désirez tout le temps allez
mesdames messieurs alors là je me dit
parenthèse effectivement christelle je
suis d'accord avec toi on n'est pas tout
le temps ego encore hommes femmes il ya
un truc sur lequel on a fini par être à
peu près égaux c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
ya autant d'hommes nus pour nous vendre
des choses que de femmes nues bonne
nouvelle moi je suis plutôt content
parce qu'en plus ils nous choisissent
pas les plus moches
dire que quand même il croit que le
désir qu on éprouverait pour ces corps
nous aiderait à acheter des produits
comment ils sont ces corps ils sont
beaux si tenté que la beauté répondent à
des critères dans cette beauté il y a
comme critère ils sont jeunes
c'est-à-dire sans stigmates de la
vieillesse sont les rides cheveux blancs
ça peut changer un peu anne va bien nous
aider à trouver les cheveux blancs sexy
bronze et musclé lis cela il aurait le
droit de faire l'amour et puis alors
l'avoir maintenant c'est fin c'est que
du sexe un peu plus trop avoir autre
chose c'est plus seulement s'embrasser
tout est explicite aujourd'hui quand on
vous nous montrait la sexualité
n'importe quel film je te prends je te
colle contre le mur je te fais si je te
fait sage et alors vous remarquerez
aussi en cette sexualité on transpire
jamais jamais n'est jamais quasiment
décoiffé ou juste par le désir si on
transpire c'est que l'homme comme ça
où il y aurait il de la place pour des
corps marqués par la vie dans cette
sexualité y en aurait pas et en plus
cette sexualité elle serait vu
aujourd'hui comme un épanouissement
comme un but à atteindre
la sexualité est devenu finalement un
critère de développement personnel alors
les vieux dont on pense vous rappeler ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure
j'espère je vous ai pas perdu en route
quand on vous disait tout à l'heure ils
n'ont pas de pensée et bien
du coup je pourrais pas faire l'amour
et continue à faire l'amour
en ehpad je vais pas vous dire que c'est
des lupanars mais alors avec cette
société aussi qui prône le maintien à
domicile le plus longtemps possible
quand vous êtes tout seul chez vous
pendant le long temps longtemps que vous
retrouvez en ehpad et j'ai même pas
besoin de vous le dire vous l'avez de
vivez vous même
surtout pour les hommes parce que on
n'est pas égaux par contre sur la
longévité et il y a deux hommes pour lui
femmes 1
bon
ça se bat ça ses chances à moi si je
m'intéresse à la sexualité en ehpad
c'est aussi parce que c'est une une
génération qui a connu sa jeunesse
sexuelles avant mai 68 et qui est donc
très empreinte d'une mentalité est qui
qui fait que elle elle s'auto censure
dans sa sexualité
elles ont connu les écoles non mixtes
là elles n'ont pas connu la
contraception l'avortement et autres ça
va changer
je porte également ce message puisque la
génération d'après les seniors ce qu'on
a des vieux vieux et des vieux jeunes
ont donc ces vieux jeunes les seniors
eux ils ont connu plus tôt une qu'une
jeunesse sexuelles sous mai 68 et ils se
sont pas protégés
ils n'ont pas eu cette cette habitude de
porter des préservatifs
pourtant aujourd'hui ça reste
indispensable
les vieux comme vous et moi
il pratique et je ne vous dirai pas quoi
je suis régulièrement en butte aux
journalistes sur cette question qui me
regardent et qui me disent alors madame
faivre dans les ehpad comment ça se
passe
et moi je leur réponds et vous comment
ça se passe
ça reste leur intimité c'est un message
d'espoir que je veux vous passez aussi
aujourd'hui
non il ne suffit pas d'être beau jeune
lice bronzés pour être désiré vous
resterez toujours désirables désirant
pour quelqu'un d'autre ça c'est une
merveilleuse nouvelle
merci